hey what's going on everybody for
everyone that is watching one of my
videos for the first time I just want to
let you guys know that I'm going to do
another giveaway this weekend and if you
want a chance to win this shirt or book
just subscribe to this channel and good
luck now let's get today's video started
and I'm just going to assume that most
of you saw the updated plot like video
that I posted the other day so just like
I've done before I'm going to break down
each one of these episodes and I will
discuss what is likely to happen or what
seems to be proven by the league set
photos so let's begin season 7 episode 3
opens up with Jon arriving at
Dragonstone where he meets Tyrion on the
beach they shake hands and talk about
Daenerys Targaryen so we absolutely know
this is going to happen unless you've
been hiding underneath of a rock lately
there have been a massive amount of
photos that have came out as Game of
Thrones films its seventh season and in
those photos there has been one of John
arriving on the beach that is being
guarded by Dothraki soldiers and when
John gets off the boat he is greeted by
Tyrion Lannister and of course I would
assume that they're going to talk about
the nares she will more than likely be
the one who asks for John to come in
Tyrion will probably briefly tell Jon
what they've been up to and what Danny's
intentions are now that she has this
huge army and has arrived in Westeros so
there's really no dispute here the photo
pretty much speaks for itself
Jon and Tyrion will definitely meet on
the beach next season and I've mentioned
this before but I will say it again
since there are so many new people here
personally I can't wait to see this
scene because I love both of these
characters I've been waiting for these
two to share screen time again for a
very long time
because their scenes and dialogue
together during season 1 was some my
favorite scenes in the entire show even
though those scenes weren't very
action-packed I just thought the things
that they discussed was very interesting
so I'm definitely looking forward to see
how their relationship continues to grow
now that they may be working together
now next it says Arya has a dream and
rides up river to find Nymeria and
just want to say in my heart I believe
we will see Nymeria again I want to see
Nymeria again but I kind of have this
bad feeling that this may not happen and
I think it would be complete [ __ ]
for the show to never explain what
happened to this direwolf I feel like
they have to bring her back I just hope
they don't bring Nymeria back just to
kill her off like they've done in the
past but I think there's only going to
be 7 episodes next season so they should
have at least the same amount of money
to spend on these episodes but it's just
going to be Leste episode so you think
they'd have more money per episode next
year so Dan and Dave if you ever hear
this please bring the damn direwolf back
they are so important to the starts and
who they are as a person and their
connections with their power
so if aria does have a dream I think it
may be that connection between the two
that sends her off to see exactly where
she is at but I highly doubt we will
ever see the wolf pack they barely spend
money for one dire wolf so it's not
likely they're going to spend money to
show twenty or fifty or a hundred of
them together but it would be incredible
if they did could you imagine Aria
pulling up at Winterfell on a horse
surrounded by fifty wolves that'd be
gangster but anyways let's move on Danny
is watching her dragons fly when John
approaches her Danny tells John to bend
the knee but he doesn't and instead
tells her to send her dragons north to
fight the white walkers she doesn't
believe him but Tyrion says John isn't
crazy and you should definitely hear
what he has to say okay one thing I know
for sure John is not going to be bending
the knee that's for sure
I think he spent way too much time with
the wildling so I don't see him ever
bending the knee again but I am hoping
we get a scene between John and Danny
where John talks about maester aemon
who was Danny's family obviously I would
like to see John tell her about him and
how great of a man he was in his vision
for the future I think that'd be pretty
cool especially since the actor Peter
Vaughn who played his maester aemon has
now died I think that would just be a
nice thing for them to do in my opinion
but Danny probably wouldn't believe
there are white walkers out there we
know Tyrion definitely didn't
in them during season one but I think so
many people at the wall was warning
Tyrion about them that I think he was
probably considering it to be true he
just really didn't show it but I think
once John tells them about the threat
and once he says he came into contact
with them face to face and was nearly
killed by one
I think Tyrion would believe him Tyrion
and John began to respect each other
during their time together at the wall
in Tyrion will know he has no reason to
lie about something like this so I do
believe if the conversation does come up
Tyrion is going to lean towards believe
in whatever John has to say and I think
he would want to help him in some way
but we know Dany has business to take
care of when Dragonstone she's one of
this her whole life and now that she is
in position to take back what she
believes to be hers I don't see her
abandoning her position to go north just
yet but we shall see
okay next it says you're on captures the
sand snakes and ilaria you're on kills
Obara because she was annoying him he
forces Nymeria to strip naked and touch
herself you're on then poisons tyene and
he forces a lorry at a watch
after that he drowns a Lauria for the
drowned gods he then tells his men that
the Ironborn will have even more glory
when he takes the reach in the western
lands alright so we definitely know from
the spoiler photos that Euron captures
the sand snakes but I actually think
this is going to happen earlier than
episode 3 reports have came out before
that this battle happens during the very
first episode before dana reaches
Dragonstone and we can see from previous
photos that Dany is on Dragonstone with
the director who will do episode 1
therefore we know she will land on
Dragonstone in the very first episode so
I think Euron will capture them before
episode 3 actually but regardless he's
definitely going to capture them
obviously but some of this other stuff
that is said to take place sounds like
[ __ ] to me I do not think your on
will be the one to kill tyene and ilaria
in these photos you're on is marching
the girls through King's Landing and I
believe he is taking them to Cersei to
hand over to her that way they can form
this new alliance and I
once Circe gets her hands on the sand
snakes she's going to be the one to have
them killed they set up Circe's daughter
to be killed so I definitely think Circe
will be the one to return the favor but
I do like what they said here when it
says that taim will be killed in front
of ilaria because I actually said the
same thing in a previous video I made
when these photos first were released I
said that I think Circe will kill tyene
in front of the Lauria for payback for
killing her daughter so I do think this
is going to take place but I think Circe
will be the one handing out the death
sentences she could have Euron do it I
guess but I feel like Cersei is going to
do much worse to the same snakes
I think Cersei would the mountain do
very bad things to them and if you watch
my other video about this it will make
much more sense but I want to move on
from this for now because I already went
over it before so check out that other
video to where I go into much more
details about what's going to take place
right here next it says Jaime returns to
King's Landing and Cersei tells Jaime
she is pregnant
Jaime then tells Cersei that Tyrion did
not kill Joffrey alright now this sounds
completely out of order to me the report
came out that Jaime battles the Tyrells
during episode 4 next season and I'm
pretty sure the director is going to be
mad shaykh Minh who's going to do
episode 4 and 5 and he was seen on set
there during these battle scenes so
there's no way Jamie's going to be able
to return from this battle in episode 3
when it's going to take place in episode
4 so a scene like this could take place
but it's not going to happen in a third
episode it would have to be at least a
fourth or fifth episode but I could see
Jaime telling Cersei that Tyrion did not
kill Joffrey we already know Jaime
doesn't believe it anyway he did help
Tyrion escape from jail while he was
awaiting his execution and if we do get
a scene where lady Elena tells Jaime
that she was the one who killed Joffrey
then Jaime would definitely want to let
Cersei know because Jamie does not want
to see his brother die of course and I
know Tyrion did kill their father and
Jaime did say he would kill Tyrion for
doing that but I personally do not
believe that I think all of time when
skids hated him to some extent and Jamie
loves to
and dearly Jamie knows time when in
searcy have one and taereung dead for a
very long time and for that Jamie has
always felt bad so I think Jamie wander
stand why Tyrion killed his father once
they are able to speak but this is just
my opinion of course but I do not see
Jaime ever killing Tyrion no way in hell
but anyways it says Jorah leaves old
town ahead to Dragonstone after hearing
Daenerys is there so he tells Sam by now
once again we know this is going to take
place next season there have already
been spoiler photos from the set that
showed Jorah on the beach with Dany
but once again the timeline is off this
is not going to take place during
episode 3 from spoiler photos we know
that Jorah will be there while Matt
Sheikh Minh is directing who once again
is going to be directing episode 4 and 5
so this does take place but it will be
much later than episode 3 and Jorah is
wearing long sleeves so we don't know
for sure if he cured his greyscale but I
do not think Jorah would risk lying to
Danny again and risking her health by
showing up with the disease Stowe and I
only mentioned this because some of you
have asked about that so I doubt Jorah
would come back while still having
greyscale and next it says Tyrion and
Davos come up with a plan to meet Jaime
to discuss Cersei surrender now from
spoiler photos we do know that Tyrion
and Davos go on some kind of a mission
and I could see Tyrion wanting to warn
Jaime as well I don't think he'd want to
see Jaime end up getting killed by
standing his ground when Tyrion knows at
some point
Dany is going to have to attack whether
Cersei wants to surrender or not so I
could see Tyrion wanting to at least
give Jaime a heads up about what's to
come but I'm not sure this mission is to
see Jaime because in the photos we know
that Davos in Tyrion come back to
Dragonstone with Gendry who then leaves
with Jon Davos and Jorah so I guess they
could kill two birds with one stone so
I'm not going to rule this out but I
can't guarantee that Tyrion and Davos go
to King's Landing specifically to see
Jaime because when they come back they
do have Gendry with them so I'm not too
sure about this
but anyways next it says Danny and John
are on the beach when she asked him to
pet a dragon which he does okay so we
have another timeline issue here there
is a photo of John holding a fake dragon
head which could be for a scene of him
petting the dragon but the director
standing in the background is matt
shaykh minh who will be doing episode
four and five so this will not happen in
Episode three but I also have an issue
with this scene because I think this is
actually complete [ __ ]
smoke and mirrors I do not think this is
a legit scene I think they did this just
to mess with people because they knew
about all the photographer's around and
they were leaking everything and there's
something about the look on Danny's face
that tells me they're just fooling
around
I do think John is going to meet the
dragons for sure but I do not think this
is going to be that scene but once again
that's just my opinion
and last but not least it says Theon
lands on the shore of Dragonstone John
tells him that if he didn't save Sansa
he would kill him
Theon then tells Danny that Euron
captures his sister or Yara and took
control of the Ironborn fleet okay so we
definitely know something like this
happens and I made a video about this a
long time ago when I first saw this
photo of John and Theon together on the
beach it's very obvious that John is
angry with Theon more than likely for
turning his back on Robb and holding
Winterfell hostage plus killing Sir
Roderick and the two little farm boys
John definitely wouldn't put up with
this [ __ ] but John does love Sansa and
would appreciate that he got her away
from Ramsay so I can't see John allowing
him to live but I do think John will
punish him in some way he may just slap
him around or demote him even more I'm
really not too sure but I don't think
John lets him get off with just a
scolding but nonetheless this scene will
take place but obviously guys I had
several issues with this episode most of
it is completely out of order and some
of the urine scenes sound a little
ridiculous even for a savage but I guess
I'm just going to have to wait and see
if any more evidence comes out to
confirm any more of this for me or the
at least the time
but luckily we know who is directing
watch episode so thanks to that it is a
little bit easier for for us to piece
this stuff together and even though some
of this stuff does seem likely and some
of it is confirmed with photos it's just
in a complete wrong episode because we
see the director standing in the
background in a lot of these shots and
we know for a fact he is not going to be
directing episode 3 so some of this
stuff can happen but just not in this
episode but anyways guys comment below
and tell me what you think about all
this stuff do you agree with me do you
disagree with me let me know but keep it
classy guys either way thanks for taking
the time to listen I do appreciate it
and I will see you guys in the next one
bye have a good day